hey guys how's it going so I'm back in
the kitchen with the Walmart MVP contest
now if you guys remember in the last
video I made my take on nachos and I
loved all of the submissions that you
guys did for this contest but today we
are going to do an original take on
pizza and I am going to be making pizza
cupcakes now I got all of these
ingredients at Walmart I would say that
I got them but I actually had my mom
cook them for me I'll put a link in the
description and an annotation to Gabe
babe who is our captain for this
challenge so you can check out their
video on how to really make it but this
is going to be my take so each of my
little cupcakes is gonna be a little bit
different I don't think I'll mess it up
so let's get started okay just you want
to make sure you put some nonstick
cooking spray in here or just you know
oh but butter unrolled Oh separate into
a triangles I have never opened one of
these before so I'm not really sure
what's gonna happen what did you gotta
open this Bree thanks Bree this is Bree
that was pretty much the coolest thing
that I've ever seen in my entire life
I'm just gonna stretch these out a
little bit and then we're going to stick
them right in right in there just unroll
you put you in like that I'm gonna try
something a little different for this
one hey I never said I was a
professional but this looks good mmm
pizza these are gonna be so delicious
everyone's gonna be like wow you're such
a good cook I'm gonna be like yep this
one doesn't look so good I think I'm
just gonna not put one in this one and
add this one to this one a sauce
inside of this and morio mice she's got
our cheese's
oh there's cheese in here holy moly I
put the little sausages in the global
salsa girls I'll put a little it seemed
a surprise
hide him in there some cheese on you mmm
my sister's a vegetarian and she's
probably gonna be the one that eats
these goes Jenna's favorite food is
pizza we'll just add some more cheese
okay now what do I think 16 to 18
minutes or until lightly browned
immediately we move and serve don't
worry okay and you go and you go look at
this holy moly I think that means you
guys are good oh heck yeah these look
actually really good y'all look you look
so cute your jammies you make one for me
yes I did um I think he's good I know
I'm actually quite impressed this is for
me look at gosh
need to give how cute is our wisest oh
do you make don't ask questions okay
just try it these are hot they're hot
just like a million
what a brilliant idea right whatever
it's a piece of cupcake thank you guys
so much for watching this video I hope
that you enjoyed it I had so much fun
doing his challenge which is the
original take on pizza and if you guys
want to enter as a reminder all you have
to do is take a picture of your Pizza
creations posted on Instagram and use
the hashtag Walmart MVP contest you guys
can get a chance to come out to LA we'll
go to the YouTube space will have an eat
and greet we'll hang out we'll make
videos and it'll be so much fun so I
look forward to seeing all of your
submissions so happy cooking I'll see
you guys later bye
so for this challenge we are going to
show you our take on pizza but we want
to see your original take on pizza too